The most common systems
actually implement ACLs.
Operating systems have, in researches
I have studied, C-lists as well and
we'll see there's some nice
properties they offer.
So how would you implement C-lists?
So first of all,
where would a C-list go?
Where would it be stored?
Remember, C-lists are per user.
C-lists we get from each row of
the access control matrix, so
it's very user.
So the natural place for it is not
going to be where we kept ACLs.
The other question one can ask
is what exactly is a capability?
A capability, remember, says you
are capable of accessing that resource.
You've been given permission
to access that resource.
So typically a capability
implementation details differ, but
is really a handle for a resource.
A reference allows you to find or locate
the resource and be able to use it.
So if you can go use the resource,
you shouldn't be able to forge
a capability for that resource.
Capabilities are sort of identifiers
you can think of them or
references or handles.
But one property the system has to
guarantee, is that these capabilities or
handle that we're talking
about are unforgeable.
So think about the user has
capabilities for a bunch of resources.
List of those capabilities is what
defines a C-list for that given user.
The way where C-list is going to go,
we have to have a catalog for
each user that we have in the system.
Similar to ACLs for each resource or
object that we had before,
here we have to have a catalog of
capabilities, and system has to
store the catalog of capabilities for
each user that we have in the system.
The main capability systems
that have been explored and
one of the interesting ones
was a system called Hydra.
It was sort of a research
project done at Carnegie Mellon.
This actually, you could have C-list
stored in objects themselves.
So everything was an object.
It was an object based system.
And objects stored a C-list.
So when you came to a certain object,
well you found new set of capabilities.
And you could then use those to access
objects that you couldn't access before.
You can access this new objects
while you are within this object.
And you could take capabilities back to
the object it came from sometimes and
not other times, and things like that.
The basic idea is that capabilities
are how you decide, or
the system makes the determination
that you can access or not.
So you,
the user has to start with a catalog and
as you execute maybe new
capabilities come your way.
And that was this example
we're talking about.
So one thing we didn't talk about is
actually how does sharing happen.
The whole idea of who can access what,
and giving access to somebody else or
the example or the quiz question we've
been doing, is how does sharing happen?
With ACLs, we didn't talk about it.
But someone who has the right to let
somebody else access a resource and
make a system column have this new
user or this user that I'm specifying
should be able to read this file foo and
what we're going to do is create
a new ACE for this user,
if one doesn't already exist, and
going to add this new access right to
that and then put that ACE in the ACL.
So the new user will be able to go and
access this file in the future.
Capabilities, what do we have to do?
Sharing is going to requite
propagation of capabilities.
The new user which should be able to
access this resource In the future.
We have to provide this user with
the capability for this resource.
So the capability has to be propagated.
But remember they shouldn't
be able to forge it,
shouldn't be able to mint a capability
unless it has been passed to them or
someone had chosen to share
the resource with them.
With capabilities sharing is going to
happen by propagation of capabilities.
I'm going to give you a capability,
you're going to find a way for you to
gain access to a capability that you can
then use to be able to use the resource.
Remember, the one difference here is
that possession of a capability means
you can access the resource.
There is no access check required
as was necessary with ACLs.